[Musique]
françaises français
mes chers compatriotes jeudi soir je me
suis adressé à vous pour évoquer la
crise sanitaire que traverse notre pays
jusqu'à lors l'épidémie de covin 19
étaient peut-être pour certains d'entre
vous une idée lointaine elle est devenue
une réalité immédiate pressante
le gouvernement a pris comme je vous
l'avais annoncé des dispositions fermes
pour freiner la propagation du virus
les crèches les écoles les collèges les
lycées les universités sont fermées
depuis ce jour samedi soir les
restaurants les bars tous les commerces
non essentiels à la vie de la nation est
également clos leurs portes
les rassemblements de plus de 100
personnes ont été interdits jamais la
france n'avait dû prendre de telles
décisions
évidemment exceptionnel évidemment
temporaire en temps de paix elles ont
été prises avec ordre préparation sur la
base de recommandations scientifiques
avec un seul objectif nous protéger face
à la propagation du virus dans la
journée de jeudi
un consensus scientifique et politique
s'est formé pour maintenir le premier
tour des élections municipales et j'ai
pris avec le premier ministre
la décision de maintenir le scrutin hier
dimanche les opérations de vote ont donc
pu se tenir
je veux ce soir remercié les services de
l'état les maires l'ensemble des
services des mairies tous ceux qui ont
tenu les bureaux de vote et qui ont donc
permis l'organisation de ce scrutin
je veux aussi saluer chaleureusement les
françaises et les français qui malgré le
contexte se sont rendus aux urnes dans
le strict respect des consignes
sanitaires des gestes barrières contre
le virus je veux aussi ce soir
adresser mes félicitations républicaines
au candidat élu au premier tour
environ trente mille communes sur 35
mille ont après ce premier tour
un conseil municipal mais dans le même
temps alors même que les personnels
soignants des services de réanimation
alerter sur la gravité de la situation
nous avons aussi vu du monde se
rassembler dans les parcs des marchés
bondés des restaurants des bars qui
n'ont pas respecté la consigne de
fermeture comme si au fond la vie
n'avait pas changé à tout ce qui
adoptant ces comportements ont bravé les
consignes je veux dire ce soir très
clairement non seulement vous ne vous
protégez pas vous et l'évolution récente
a montré que personne n'est invulnérable
et compris les plus jeunes mais vous ne
protégez pas les autres même si vous ne
présentait aucun symptôme
vous pouvez transmettre le virus même si
vous ne présentait aucun symptôme vous
risquer de contaminer vos amis vos
parents vos grands parents de mettre en
danger la santé de ceux qui vous sont
chers dans le grand test dans les hauts
de france en ile de france
nos soignants se bat pour sauver des
vies avec dévouement avec force au
moment où la situation sanitaire se
dégrade fortement où la pression sur nos
hôpitaux et nos soignants s'accentue
tout notre engagement
toute notre énergie toute notre force
doivent se concentrer sur un seul
objectif ralentir la progression du
virus
je vous le redis avec force ce soir
respectons les gestes barrières les
consignes sanitaires
c'est le seul moyen de protéger les
personnes vulnérables d'avoir moins de
concitoyens infectés et ainsi de réduire
la pression sur les services de
réanimation pour qu'ils puissent mieux
accueillir mieux soigner sans signes
graves contactons notre médecin traitant
n'appelons le samu et ne nous rendons à
l'hôpital qu'en cas de forte fièvre de
difficultés à respirer sans quoi il
pourront faire face à la vague de cas
graves qui déjà se profile dans
certaines régions faisons preuve au fond
d'esprit solidaire et de sens des
responsabilités
chacun d'entre nous doit à tout prix
limiter le nombre de personnes avec qui
il est en contact chaque jour les
scientifiques le disent c'est la
priorité absolue c'est pourquoi après
avoir consulté écouter les experts le
terrain et en conscience j'ai décidé de
renforcer encore les mesures pour
réduire nos déplacements et nos contacts
au strict nécessaire dès demain midi et
pour quinze jours au moins nos
déplacements seront très fortement
réduit cela signifie que les
regroupements extérieur les réunions
familiales ou amicales ne seront plus
permises se promener retrouver ses amis
dans le parc dans la rue ne sera plus
possible
il s'agit de limiter au maximum ses
contacts au delà du foyer partout sur le
territoire français en métropole comme
outre-mer seules doivent demeurer les
trajets nécessaire nécessaire pour aller
faire ses courses avec de la discipline
et en mettant les distance d'au moins un
mètre en ne serrant pas la main en
embrassant pas les trajets nécessaire
pour se soigner
évidemment les trajets nécessaire pour
aller travailler quand le travail à
distance n'est pas possible et les
trajets nécessaires pour faire un peu
d'activité physique mais sans retrouver
là encore des amis ou des proches toutes
les entreprises doivent s'organiser pour
faciliter le travail à distance et quand
cela ne sera pas possible
elles devront adapter dès demain leur
organisation pour faire respecter ces
gestes barrière contre le virus c'est à
dire protéger leurs salariés ou quand il
s'agit d' indépendants se protéger même
le gouvernement précisera les modalités
de ces nouvelles règles dès ce soir
d après mon allocution toute infraction
à ces règles sera sanctionné je vous le
dis avec beaucoup de solennité ce soir
écoutons les soignants qui nous disent
si vous voulez nous aider il faut rester
chez vous et limiter les contacts c'est
le plus important
évidemment ce soir je pose des règles
nouvelles nous posons des interdits il y
aura des contrôles mais la meilleure
règle c'est celle qu'en tant que citoyen
vous vous appliquez à vous même et une
fois encore j'en appelle à votre sens
des responsabilités et de la solidarité
dans ce contexte après avoir consulté le
président du sénat le président de
l'assemblée nationale mais également mes
prédécesseurs j'ai décidé que le second
tour des élections municipales serait
reporté le premier ministre en a informé
aujourd'hui même les chefs de partis
représentés au parlement
cette décision a fait l'objet d'un
accord unanime
mes chers compatriotes je mesure
l'impact de toutes ses décisions sur vos
vies renoncé à voir ses proches
c'est un déchirement stopper ses
activités quotidiennes ses habitudes
c'est très difficile cela ne doit pas
nous empêcher de garder le lien
d'appeler nos proches de donner des
nouvelles d'organiser aussi les choses
avec nos voisins d'inventer de nouvelles
solidarités entre générations de rester
comme je voulais dit jeudi dernier
profondément solidaire et d'innover là
aussi sur ce point je sais que je vous
demande de rester chez vous je vous
demande aussi de garder le calme
dans ce contexte
j'ai vu ces dernières heures des
phénomènes de panique en tous sens nous
devons tous avoir l'esprit de
responsabilité il faut pas que les
fausses d'informations circulent à tout
va et en restant chez vous occupez vous
des proches qui sont dans votre
appartement votre maison donner des
nouvelles prenait des nouvelles
lisez retrouvez aussi ce sens de
l'essentiel
je pense que c'est important dans les
moments que nous vivons la culture
l'éducation le sens des choses est
important et éviter l'esprit de panique
de croire dans toutes les fausses
rumeurs
les demis experts les faux sachant la
parole est clair l'information est
transparente et nous continuerons de
l'aisne
mais croyez moi cet effort que je vous
demande
je sais qu'il est inédit mais les
circonstances nous y oblige
nous sommes en guerre en guerre
sanitaire certes nous luttons n'est
contre une armée n'est contre une autre
nation mais l'ennemi est là invisible
insaisissable qui progresse et cela
requiert notre mobilisation générale
nous sommes en guerre toute l'action du
gouvernement et du parlement doit être
désormais tournés vers le combat contre
l'épidémie
de jour comme de nuit rien ne doit nous
en divertir c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé
que toutes les réformes en cours
seraient suspendus à commencer par la
réforme des retraites dès mercredi en
conseil des ministres sera présenté un
projet de loi permettant au gouvernement
de répondre à l'urgence
et lorsque nécessaire de légiférer par
ordonnance dans les domaines relevant
strictement de la gestion de crise ce
projet sera soumis au parlement dès
jeudi
j'ai vu tout à l'heure les présidents de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat afin
que ce texte soit voté le plus
rapidement possible afin aussi que la
vie démocratique et le contrôle du
parlement continue dans cette période je
les en remercie et je remercie tous nos
parlementaires en cet instant nous
sommes en guerre
j'appelle tous les acteurs politiques
économiques sociaux associatifs tous les
français à s'inscrire dans cette union
nationale qui a permis à notre pays de
surmonter tant de crises par le passé
nous sommes en guerre et la nation
soutiendra ses enfants qui personnel
soignant en ville à l'hôpital se trouve
en première ligne dans un combat qui va
leur demander énergie détermination
solidarité ils ont des droits sur nous
nous leur devons évidemment les moyens
la protection nous serons là nous leur
devons des masques du gel tout le
matériel nécessaire et nous y veillons
et y veilleront nous avons décidé avec
les scientifiques de réserver les
masques en priorité pour l'hôpital et
pour la médecine de ville et de campagne
en particulier les généralistes les
infirmières désormais en première ligne
aussi dans la gestion de la crise des
masques seront livrés dans les
pharmacies dès demain soir dans les 25
départements les plus touchés mercredi
pour le reste du territoire national
j'ai aussi entendu le message des
spécialistes en particulier les
chirurgiens dentistes et beaucoup
d'autres
des solutions seront trouvées avec le
ministre de la santé dans les prochaines
heures
nous devons aussi aux soignants la garde
de leurs enfants
un service minimum de garde est en place
depuis ce jour dans les crèches et dans
les écoles nous leur devons aussi
sérénité dans leurs déplacements et
repos
c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé que dès
demain les taxis et les hôtels pourront
être mobilisés à leur profit l'état
paiera nous sommes en guerre
oui le pays accompagnera dans cette
période
les régions les plus touchées
aujourd'hui comme celles qui le seront
demain
à ce titre je veux assurer les habitants
les personnels soignants du grand test
que nous serons rendez vous pour les
appuyer
face à l'afflux de patients et à la
saturation des hôpitaux
je sais ce qu'ils vivent depuis des
jours et des jours
nous sommes avec eux j'ai décidé pour
cela qu'un hôpital de campagne du
service de santé des armées seraient
déployés dans les jours à venir en
alsace les armes et apporteront aussi
leur concours pour déplacer les malades
des régions les plus affectées et ainsi
réduire la congestion des hôpitaux de
certains territoires
nous sommes en guerre aussi comme je
voulais dit jeudi pour nous protéger et
contenir la dissémination du virus mais
aussi préserver nos systèmes de soins
nous avons pris ce matin entre européens
une décision commune dès demain midi les
frontières à l'entrée de l'union
européenne et de l'espace schengen
seront fermés concrètement tous les
voyages entre les pays non européens et
l'union européenne seront suspendues
pendant 30 jours
les françaises et les français qui sont
actuellement à l'étranger et souhaite
rentrer pourront bien entendu rejoindre
leur pays nous devons prendre cette
décision parce que je vous demande ce
soir d'importants efforts et que nous
devons dans la durée nous protéger et je
veux dire à tous nos compatriotes qui
vivent à l'étranger que là aussi en bon
ordre
ils doivent se rapprocher des ambassades
et consulats et que nous organiserons
pour celles et ceux qui le souhaitent
et là où c'est nécessaire
le rapatriement vous l'aurez compris
vous le présentez cette crise sanitaire
sans précédent aura des conséquences
humaines sociales économiques majeures
c'est aussi ce défi que nous devons
mener
je vous demande des sacrifices pour
ralentir l'épidémie
jamais ils ne doivent mettre en cause
l'aide aux plus fragiles la pérennité
d'une entreprise les moyens de
subsistance des salariés comme des
indépendants pour les plus précaires
pour les plus démunis pour les personnes
isolées
nous ferons en sorte avec les grandes
associations avec aussi les
collectivités locales et leurs services
qu'ils puissent être nourri protégés que
les services que nous leur devons soit
assurée pour la vie économique
pour ce qui concerne la france aucune
entreprise quelle que soit sa taille ne
sera livré au risque de faillite
aucune française aucun français ne sera
laissée sans ressources
s'agissant des entreprises nous mettons
en place un dispositif exceptionnel de
reports de charges fiscales et sociales
de soutien report d'échéances bancaires
et de garanties de l'état à hauteur de
300 milliards d'euros pour tous les
prêts bancaires contractés auprès des
banques pour les plus petites d'entre
elles étant que la situation dure à
celles qui font face à des difficultés
n'auront rien à débourser
ni pour les impôts ni pour les
cotisations sociales les factures d'eau
de gaz ou d'électricité ainsi que les
loyers devront être suspendus
en outre afin que personne ne soit
laissé son ressources pour les salariés
le dispositif de chômage partiel sera
massivement élargie comme je vous
l'avais annoncé jeudi dernier
et comme le gouvernement a commencé à le
préciser pour les entrepreneurs
commerçants artisans un fonds de
solidarité sera créé abondé par l'état
et auquel le premier ministre proposera
aux régions aussi de contribuer le
gouvernement dès demain précisera toutes
ces mesures elles seront en fonction des
besoins
les réalités économiques des nécessités
secteur par secteur
évidemment adapté nous serons au rendez
vous pour que notre économie soit
préservée dans cette période si dur et
pour que l'ensemble les travailleuses
des travailleurs puissent avoir cette
sécurité aussi en termes de pouvoir
d'achat de continuité de leur vie mes
chers compatriotes la france vit un
moment très difficile
nul ne peut en prévoir précisément la
durée et à mesure que les jours suivront
les jours que les problèmes succéderont
au problème il faudra en lien avec les
éclairages donné par les scientifiques
les expériences de terrain il faudra
nous adapter nous allons continuer aussi
pendant cette période de travail et de
progresser sur les traitements et je
sais le dévouement de plusieurs équipes
partout sur notre territoire avec les
premiers espoirs qui naissent et nous
continuerons aussi d'avancer sur le
vaccin
régulièrement je m'adresserai à vous je
vous dirai à chaque fois comme je lé
fais comme le gouvernement le fait la
vérité sur l'évolution de la situation
j'ai une certitude plus nous agirons
ensemble et vite
plus nous surmonterons cette épreuve
plus nous agirons en citoyen plus nous
ferons preuve de la même force d'âme de
la même abnégation patriotes que
démontre aujourd'hui nos personnels
soignants nos sapeurs pompiers
l'ensemble des acteurs de la sécurité
civile plus vite nous sortirons de cette
vie au ralenti
nous y arriverons mes chers compatriotes
en étant unie solidaire
je vous demande d'être responsables tous
ensemble et de ne céder à aucune panique
d'accepter ces contraintes de les porter
de les expliquer de vous les appliquez à
vous mêmes nous nous les appliquerons
tous
il n'y aura pas de passe-droit mais là
aussi de ne céder ni à la panique ni au
désordre
nous gagnerons
mais cette période nous aura beaucoup
appris beaucoup de certitudes de
conviction sont balayées seront remises
en cause beaucoup de choses que nous
pensions
impossible advienne
ne nous laissons pas impressionner
agissons avec force mais retenons cela
le jour d'après quand nous aurons gagné
ce ne sera pas un retour jour d'avant
nous serons plus forts moralement nous
aurons appris et je saurai aussi avec
vous en tirer toutes les conséquences
toutes les conséquences ils sont nous
individuellement et collectivement à la
hauteur du moment je sais mes chers
compatriotes pouvoir compter sur vous
vive la république vive la france
[Musique]